here's what would happen if you were
stranded in Antarctica
if you're not scared of killer carbon
dioxide try living in the ice caves of
Erebus one of two active volcanoes in
Antarctica sounds cool pun intended but
all the gas would likely put you in a
coma
best to build yourself a snow fort
shelter instead
of feeling peckish well try Emperor
penguin it would be an oily snack that
tastes a bit like chicken but get used
to a raw food diet a cooking fire on
Antarctica it would be hard to spark UV
rays bouncing off the snow could cause
you to go snow blind whereas shifting
ice sheets or the occasional blizzard
could disorient you and send you
plunging down a snowy Canyon to your
death you would face temperatures as low
as minus 60 degrees Celsius and winds as
high as 320 kilometers per hour so